so today we're going to talk about
recent events in a couple of African
nations as I'm sure you've noticed this
is front-page news in the alternate
universe where people care more about
the health and well-being of others than
they care about the narcissistic
personality disorders of American
actresses part one Chad no not Chad or
Chad or Chad Chad Chad being of course
the landlocked nation in Central Africa
with two traffic lights in the entire
country neither of which work Chad being
the country where an amazingly corrupt
dictator and his government are at war
with even more corrupt rebel forces so
Hank right now in Chad there's no war
going on but once the roads become
passable again the war will restart
because it restarts every year and you
know how wars have good guys and bad
guys and there's one team you root for
and one team you root against there's an
allies and an axis there's a rebel and
an empire this isn't a war like that and
in fact very few of the wars in Africa
right now are like that which is part of
the reason they don't get a lot of news
coverage it's because it's not easy to
tell a story that makes sense when we
look at why this stuff happens you can't
say oh it's tribalism it's been
happening forever because that's not
actually true I mean there is tribalism
in Chad but as anyone who's ever been to
an Alabama Auburn football game can
attest there's also tribalism in America
and when we lament Wars like this we
have to acknowledge that the people who
are fighting them are responsible they
need to stop fighting right now but
we've also got to acknowledge that
colonialism screwed the world up a ton I
think I'd like to share with you a quote
from a Wikipedia page about Chad the
French first penetrated Chad in 1891 Oh
Wikipedia sometimes you're inaccurate
sometimes you're accurate and sometimes
you are even more accurate than even you
realize how did it feel when the French
penetrated you uh it was uncomfortable I
I didn't enjoy I was afraid
and then after 1891 did the French ever
penetrate you again oh my yes they
penetrated me repeatedly part two
pirates here played by Willie because I
don't have any pictures of actual
pirates okay so quick historical
background Somalia is a country on the
east coast of Africa it gained its
independence in 1960 in 1969 it had a
military coup because that's what
everybody was doing back in 1969 and a
guy from that military coup general
beret maintained power until 1991 at
which point there was a coup and he was
removed in favor of no one no joke Hank
nobody took power
so since 1991 in lieu of having a
government Somalia has split up into
three
semi autonomous regions in the South you
have the total anarchy of no functioning
government there's been a 20-year long
civil war in the last few years there's
been a battle between these Islamist
militants who would impose sort of
Taliban style Islamic law in Somalia and
then on the other side you've had
everyone else who's like as bad as
anarchy is that sounds worse the US and
Somalia's neighbours tend to support
that second option which means that for
the last few years we've put all our
weight behind the transitional federal
government of Somalia which is
ostensibly running the South although
given that the transitional federal
government has been around for nine
years it has a funny way of being
transitional and given that its
influence only extends to a third of the
country it has a funny way of being
federal and given its complete inability
to do even the most rudimentary tasks
associated with governance it has a
funny way of being a government then in
the far northwest bordering Djibouti
which I'm obviously only mentioning so
that I can say Djibouti we have
Somaliland Somaliland is actually like a
functioning democracy with its own
currency and economy and everything then
finally on the northeast coast you have
Puntland which I'm probably
mispronouncing which has become the
world capital of piracy in fact in the
last year it's estimated that Somali
pirates from twenty-one hundred fifty
million dollars in ransom Hank in a
country where the average person makes a
dollar fifty a day a hundred fifty
million dollars is a lot of Djibouti
sorry but seriously Hank in the context
of the larger Somalian tragedy I would
argue that the problem with piracy while
serious is a little bit marginal sorry
so here's my question who's at fault for
the piracy who's at fault for the wars
and Chad is the combatants themselves is
it France and Italy and Britain for
their disastrous colonization's of these
countries is it us for not paying
attention to these wars in which tens of
thousands of real people are really
dying
those aren't rhetorical questions I
really want answers Hank congratulations
on the hugely successful release of your
first album by Hanks album I can't wait
for the first song Wednesday I'll see
you then if I don't see you before